plus de 900 morts civiles 2616 blessés
et près de 150 otages c'est un bilan
humain provisoire mais déjà sans
précédent qui a été annoncé mardi par
les autorités israéliennes 4 jours après
l'attaque massive lancée par le Hamas
contre les thabreux parmi les victimes
quatre Français tués et 13 disparus BT
certains ont très probablement été
enlevés selon le ministère français des
Affaires étrangères c'est désormais la
question qui hante des centaines de
familles israéliennes où sont leurs
proches et dans quel conditions sont-ils
détenus hommes femmes enfants civils
mais aussi militaires dont certains haut
gradés l'ampleur des ENL visant la
population israélienne est inédite pour
un pays pourtant habitué aux prise
d'otage depuis sa création en 1948 ses
détenus sont aujourd'hui un butin
précieux pour les forces du Hamas qui
cherchent à obtenir la libération des
quelques 4500 palestiniens détenus dans
les jaules israéliennes pour activités
terroristes surtout alors que l'armée
israélienne a annoncé lundi le siège
complet de la bande de Gaza les otages
servent aujourd'hui de bouclier humain
pour les combattants du Hamas
palestinien chaque fois que notre peuple
sera pris pour cible sans avertissement
cela entraînera l'exécution d'un des h
pour les renseignements israéliens la
course contre la montre est lancée avant
de s'engager dans une probable opération
militaire contre la bande de Gaza
l'urgence est de localiser les
ressortissants kidnappés une tâche ardue
dans ce territoire côtier peuplé de 2,3
millions de Palestiniens et entièrement
contrôlé par le Hamas depuis 2007 depuis
qu'Israël a quitté la bande de Gaza en
2005 le nombre de collaborateurs
Palestiniens à la solde d'Israël a
vraisemblablement chuté en face les
islamistes qui sont épolés
logistiquement par le Hezbollah la
milice chite libanaise et l'Iran ont
considérablement renforcé leur contre
mesure